Viktor Aleksandrovich maintenant je suis déjà
dit qu'il y a une telle confrontation
légèrement divisé les Biélorusses en deux
pièces à votre avis pour certains
sportif si on le dit
fête du sport
vous reconnaîtrez en général la séparation des peuples dofiga
chacun est caractéristique, par conséquent, l'objectif de notre
par exemple, l'action en cours dans la leçon
consultation d'excuses des nations ici c'est sur
l'un des principaux domaines où
peut-il
notre elle était une équipe nous avons toujours marché
à un but défendu l'honneur de notre pays
et pour que vous disiez, eh bien, disons-le à votre
rival idéologique à rival
peut-être cinq ans par adversaire
vous connaissez
besoin de prendre
courir ici tourment
pense bien pense et presque
correct
c'est bien quand des opinions différentes ne sont pas un partisan
diesel donc c'est très bon je
J'aimerais toujours que nous soyons différents
avis étaient
et pas tout à fait côte à côte, mais quand
quand ton pays a rendu difficile
situations comment cela dépend du sort du pays
il y a un fond qu'il faut être uni quelque part et
essayez tout de même bien avec ce droit
il y a une année scolaire